moving that is the most obvious out of
all of them but it has a clear downside
to it okay he moves his bishop i
mentioned that this is on the radar
attacking the white queen but the white
oh
look at that
is that a blunder yeah
i think we're going to see a nice
checkmating attack white's light squared
bishop now is going to come to the
center of the board giving a check and
i'm trying to work out ivanka can white
just give up the queen that's what i'm
working out um yeah let's we've got to
share it right because it is possible
it's going to be a brutal mating attack
just keep an eye on the players look at
mama jarov though look at the
laser sharp focus that he's suddenly got
on his face he is super interested in
this position and that's because right
now white can give a check hitting the
black king only one safe square to go to
you have to move and now you can give up
the white queen you can ignore the
threat against her okay the first
check's on the board you can bring your
rook up the board take a pawn and after
the queen drops suddenly you give a
check this is very simple if the king
goes to the center wow he sacrifices
queen he didn't even think and now this
would be checkmate if the king goes to
the center if it goes the other way then
uh this is checkmate as well
look at this the king will be checkmated
in the corner of the board a double
check and we have a result amazing
checkmate there from mamadourov wow
after 26 moves it is over between these
two shakriya and mamadiaro taking all
three points